thank you very much
Oldsmobile and now back to New York and
miss Celeste home well Thank You Jerry
that's very nice except I have nothing
to say you what I say I have nothing to
say everything suppose did you do start
him alone
no Jerry he's in Hollywood with you here
with me in this place the RKO and
educator with me
is that him alone in this in here Oh
live without a Kinney important well
then I'll introduce the young lady
ladies and gentleman I take pride and
pleasure introducing a beautiful young
lady who's been nominated for her role
and written on the wind as Best Actress
in a supporting role the lovely Miss
Dorothy Malone
oh I did daddy just fine Jerry it's good
to see you I mean I didn't mind you in
the pictures and all that I like to see
you like this this is a very auspicious
occasion and you've been chosen the
master of ceremonies so you're supposed
to pretend that you are dear to me aha
well I don't attend that I do have
dignity yes that you are erudite well
this I can be at easy enough you just be
it uh I bet you don't know what it means
I don't know what it means
mm-hmm erudite an adjective meaning to
free from rudeness to polish instruct
characterized by extensive knowledge of
a bookish nature learn it from the Latin
erudite us applauding is pretty hot
ladies and gentlemen ever since the
motion picture found its voice the
science of recorded sound has become an
art and those have been chosen best in
their fields this year our Don Myers for
the brave one Columbia sound Department
for the Eddy Duchin story West direct
sound services and the Samuel Goldwyn
sound department for friendly persuasion
20th Century Fox sound department for
the King and I and paramount sound
department for the 10 commandments the
envelope please and the winner is the
King and I
thank you very much and congratulations